okay
uh welcome everyone uh my name is
stephen nair and i'm the director of the
fortune off video archive
for holocaust testimonies and it really
is an honor
for the archive to be hosting this event
this morning to celebrate
the enormous scholarly contributions of
professor lawrence langer
and welcome the publication of a series
of articles in his honor
in honor of his story career and
influence entitled interrogating evil
a special issue of the journal of
holocaust research for lawrence
langer on his 90th birthday larry's not
only the most important living thinker
and writer on the topic of holocaust
testimonies
from the fortune of video archive but
he's also helped to build the archive
having served as an interviewer on
over 80 testimonies recorded by the
archive since the late 1980s
it's impossible for me to overstate the
enormous influence larry has had on the
shape of this archive
and its reception in the scholarly
community but i suspect
other speakers today will address that
much better than i can
i would like to make one tiny
announcement that i think is relevant
and i hope larry will appreciate
and that is it uh i met recently with
representatives of yale university press
and um together we are discussing the
creation of a multimedia version of
larry's book holocaust testimonies ruins
of memory
which would combine the text of his
groundbreaking work with the original
excerpts from the testimonies upon which
larry
based his research in doing so ruins of
memory will not only
continue to tell us about its own
important insights that can be drawn
from testimony but it will show us
those important insights larry i hope to
have it ready
for you before your 92nd birthday
biswinder zwanzig so now i'd like
to hand things over to michaela roroni
michal is the editor of the journal of
holocaust research and is a teaching
fellow at ben green university
she received her phd in political
science from the new school
for social research in 2010 her research
and teaching interests include history
of political ideas
in modern political thought and
holocaust studies she's the author of
hannah arn in the limits of total
domination the holocaust plurality and
resistance
from rutledge 2015 and numerous articles
and chapters
nicole you have the floor
hope don't forget to unmute
hi can you hear me now hi
so hello everyone good morning here in
israel it's already
five in the afternoon and
i'm very happy to be here in this
special
event to honor professor langer
a 90th birthday and his great
contribution to holocaust studies
and i want to say uh just uh
briefly a few words about the journal
for
the sake of people who don't know the
journal
so the journal of holocaust research
formerly known as the pim
is the academic journal of the vice
slivnath
international center for holocaust
research and education
at the university of haifa it is
published
in with a cooperation with
taylor and francis um publication
and we publish each year
four volumes in english and also
once a year a value a bigger volume in
hebrew so it's bilingual
and on behalf of the journal i would
like to take this opportunity
to thank um first of all
larry for giving us the opportunity
to publish this special volume
in his honor and also for his beautiful
article that he contributed for this
volume and
second i would like to thank the three
guest editors
don scorsevsky dan stone
and gabrielle finder thank you for
your wonderful cooperation and for all
the
effort and hard work and that made this
special volume possible and
for me personally it was a great
privilege
to work with all of you and of course
to read larry's piece and to work
carefully on all these
all the very interesting and great
articles that all of you contributed
and we worked hard
for over i think one year and a half
and i'm very happy to be here tonight
and finally i want to thank um
the fortune of video archive at yale
university
for organizing this special event
so thank you everyone and i hope
everyone will enjoy this webinar
thank you mikhail and thank you stephen
i'd just like to
say a few words on behalf of the editors
that's
dawn and gabby and myself um
first of all we'd like to say thank you
to the fortune of
archive for hosting this event which of
course would have been nicer in person
but
um such uh
such is life i have to put up with with
this instead
but maybe at some point we'll be able to
do something uh in
in person but it's wonderful stephen to
hear of the plans for
uh for larry's book that's really uh
that's really exciting
and secondly uh to thank mikhail because
what she said
is is true a lot a lot of work has gone
into this
journal and um we as editors i think are
extremely pleased with the results in
the end we've got a great range
of articles very different uh sorts of
contributions
but all of them uh reflecting on
and celebrating larry's work and
that's the the point we're really happy
uh to be able to present this
collection uh to larry slightly late uh
for his 90th birthday only a year late
but you know never mind what's the year
and so um congratulations
to larry and i'm now going to invite
each of the contributors to
speak very briefly for three or four
minutes each um
in the order that they appear in the
journal
and then i'll invite larry to respond
and then if there are any questions uh
in the chat or in the q a
then i will uh read out as many as we
can in the time that we have
available to us so i'd like first to ask
uh
joanne rudolph to speak joanne is the
laurel fox vlog
fellow at the fortune of archive at yale
john
oops unmute joanne
there we go thank you dan um thank you
michal
and thank you steven hello to the
authors most of whom i know and a
special
special hello to larry hello also to
everyone else who has taken the time to
be with us for this wonderful occasion
even if only virtually and thank you to
the fortune off video
archive for initiating and hosting this
event
when i was approached on april 5th 2019
to write this piece for the journal
i was first delighted to hear that my
good friend
and mentor extraordinaire larry langer
was to be honored on the occasion of his
90th birthday
with a special issue of the journal
second i was very pleased to be part of
this effort
my journal article has a research focus
documenting larry's career
the history of the fortune off video
archive for holocaust testimonies
the connections between larry and
fortuneof since 1984
and the symbiosis resulting in
extraordinary
intellectual and research impact
since its beginning and continuing to
the present
and into the future in contrast to the
research focus of the article
today i will focus on the personal
larry is extraordinarily generous
in sharing his experience and his
expertise
he is always willing to share his phone
number with anyone interested in
discussing his work
particularly with young scholars he
invites them to his home
he recommends to them what they should
be reading and viewing
and even more important he listens to
their ideas
and learns from them i have always
considered myself
among one of the luckiest of those
working in our field
because of my mentors my extraordinary
mentors jeffrey hartman
sam caso dana klein
sander rosenstein and larry langer
no course no degree program
no seminar could begin to cover what i
have learned from all of them
in particular larry taught me how to
view
video testimonies when i began this work
although each testimony had a huge
impact on me
i was really at a loss in terms of
seeing patterns
and critical analysis larry's generosity
in sharing his ideas
contributed greatly to my own
development as a scholar
as an archivist as a documentarian and
as a writer
i dare say there are countless others
who would say
the very same thing larry's sense of
humor
his optimism his respect for others
and his ethics in terms of holocaust
survivors and testimonies
but equally important his life
combined with his tremendous intellect
his insatiable curiosity and impulse to
continually add to his knowledge
his wit his incomparable writing
all combined to make him truly a giant
in our field
not only in the academy but in the world
at large
his loving and close family are the
focus of his life
my zading my grandpa would call him a
mensch
a talmud hochum and perhaps even alamed
vovnik
my zadie would also have me say to larry
today
be a hundred swansec larry i wish you
many more simchas
and many more great grandchildren
particularly seeing the immense joy that
the babies
dana and maya have brought to you larry
lachaim
thank you so much uh joanne that's
really a lovely way to
to begin um can i next ask
uh jennifer jennifer geddes to speak uh
jennifer
is a professor in the department of
religious studies at the university of
virginia thank you i am delighted to be
here today
and really honored to have been asked to
contribute an essay to this special
issue
of the journal of holocaust research so
many thanks to the editors don dan and
gabi for all your work and bringing the
issue into being
and thanks to the fortune of archive for
organizing this event today
like all of us here i have learned so
much from reading
larry langer's work learning that has
influenced my writing
and my teaching i have seen the light of
realization on my students faces
as they encountered his concept of
choiceless choice
and its implications for thinking about
the holocaust
i have seen them begin to understand
their own temptations to domesticate the
holocaust
after reading his descriptions of the
ways we try to preempt
use and abuse the holocaust and they
have come to see the inadequacy of
language in grappling with the holocaust
through his work
as larry tells us quote the ghastly
details of the holocaust
are a constant reminder of the abyss
separating the lived
experience of those who endured it from
the language that seeks to describe it
end quote in my essay consider
if levy langer a ganban and the
unthinkable
i bring some of these things i have
learned from langer's work into
conversation with primo levies
if this is a man and giorgio agamben's
remnants of auschwitz
beginning with charlotte delbo's
distinction between the worst and the
unthinkable
i try to explore the unthinkable as
marking not the impossibility of
thought but rather a space that requires
us to engage
in sustained reflection that refuses
clear
judgments or conclusions i suggest
that levy's use of the hypothetical of
if clauses
creates such a space and commands us to
engage in this kind of reflection
specifically i explore levy's command
that we consider if the men and women on
the brink of exhaustion and death
in the concentration camps those who
have been called the muscle men are
are human i suggest that this activity
of considering
if is one that must not come to a
conclusion
that is characterized by hesitation that
requires a bracketing of con
conclusion i then connect this mode of
ongoing reflection
in which judgment is bracketed to
langer's idea of choiceless choice
suggesting that it too calls for an
ongoing attention
and engagement with the testimonies of
survivors along with a bracketing of
moral judgment
and finally i turned to a gambin's
meditation on the muslim men
in remnants of auschwitz arguing that
while the book
seems to be precisely this kind of
reflection
without judgment or resolution agamemn
actually
fails to keep open the space of
reflection conflating victim and
perpetrator in the process
where levy hesitates and langer advises
caution
a gambin advances conclusions
in the end i suggest that the
unthinkable while sometimes functioning
as a cliche can also mark a space
in which we are called to dwell listen
and consider if a reflection that cannot
conclude
or assert confident conclusions i think
this
caution this willingness to continue to
engage the ghastly details that cannot
be fully understood
is something that langer's work has
again and again
taught me and i am very grateful and
happy birthday
thank you jennifer um that's really
wonderful and also
uh lovely comments to hear um
so our next speaker is sarah horowitz
who is a professor at the kosciutzki
center for jewish studies
at york university so sarah
thank you um i'm going to uh
echo my colleagues in thanking the
editors
of this volume and of the journal itself
for bringing this
into fruition i know it's always
difficult to um
to wrangle essays into a cohesive volume
as they have done
but i do want to suggest that their task
was made a little bit lighter
by the inspiration that the honoree
has for all of us contributors
and i want to begin by briefly saying
that
in a field that's been dominated and
perhaps rightly so by
historians the study of the holocaust
larry langer is a luminary he brought
the tools and methodologies of literary
scholarship
to deepen and enrich thinking about the
holocaust he's influenced people in a
range of discipline
with his rigorous insightful and
powerful
voice he has not only teased out
the subtleties and nuances of writing
and testimonies about the holocaust but
he's also been a steady critic
of cultural misappropriations of the
holocaust and
and calling out as a kind of bad faith
the tendencies to view the shoah through
a redemptive lens his work has always
been characterized by
clear thinking and writing by passion
and by
a steady moral compass i met larry as a
graduate student in the late 80s when i
asked him
on our first meeting whether everything
had already been said about holocaust
literature and i think
larry's own work since the late 70s
is certainly evidence that it had not
yet been
already said uh as i said larry's been a
luminary in the field for me has he's
been more he's been
a generous mentor and um truly a
lifelong
inspiration and uh so happy birthday
and as we say in yiddish suleiman you're
a very long life
um i'm going to briefly summarize my
contribution to the volume
which very much bears the imprint of
larry's insistence that we uh
not look for redemptive narratives about
the holocaust
uh i my article is a reading of the
belated memoir of the by the french
philosopher sarah kaufman
placed in the context of fictional and
non-fictional accounts
by writers who like kaufman survive the
shaw as
children kaufman was a child in paris
born to immigrant parents from poland
who were orthodox jews her father was
the rabbi of a paris synagogue he was
tipped off in advance about what came to
be called the
veldive rafla and after warning his
congregants he returned home to his own
apartment
and waited to be arrested hoping that in
so doing he would buy
time for his wife and six children and
indeed he did he was murdered in
auschwitz but the rest of his family
survived
the memoir centers on a period of time
when sarah as a child
and her mother lived out the war
sheltered by a french catholic
neighbor who took them into her
apartment more than 30 years after the
liberation of paris
kauffman initiated the process to have
her rescuer
designated by yad hashem as one of the
righteous among the nations
but her memoir focuses on
what you might call the dark side of
being a hidden child
it would appear that sarah is very lucky
she never was separated from her mother
and she lived out the war as did
all of her siblings but the memoir
focuses on the way
her relationship with this woman
and the increasing powerlessness of her
own
mother caused a a stress a break in the
relationship with her mother
and a kind of attenuation of her
relationship to judaism
as well i put this in the context of
writers like abelfeld
and louis begley where we can see
in the account of children during the
holocaust
a kind of um auntie buildings roman in
other words a kind of um
undoing of the self undoing of the
foundations of the self so that who they
become later
is um severely marked by what they went
through
the memo was written in sarah kaufman's
60th year and shortly before
her suicide by gas and it functions in a
sense
as a coda to her more abstract and
intellectual work
published several years earlier called
parole
or smothered words there she asks how
can it be
said and how can it not be said in her
in her work i very much um i'm indebted
to larry's insistence
that we see not only what it is that
people
say in their writing but also the things
that they cannot say
and and often that they cannot bear to
think so
thank you larry for being um my moral
compass
thank you sarah um more lovely comments
i see some common threads developing
here uh which i'll
comment on a little later um our next
speaker
then is um noah schenker uh
noah is uh based at the australian
center for jewish civilization at
monash university in australia and we're
particularly grateful to him for
being here since it's about two o'clock
in the morning um
where he is so uh no if you're still
awake then
we'd love to hear from you though i
write about artificial intelligence i am
i'm currently sentient
um i just want to start by saying that
though i've only
known larry for the last
six or seven years i remember first
meeting him
um at uh ajs the association for jewish
studies i believe it was in baltimore
and i was just
greatly intimidated by the prospect of
meeting someone who had looned so large
for me and and i
just recall um the warmth
and his generosity and his
his frank and um and
and honest views um on and everything
including my own work which were just
incredibly foundational um
to helping me pursue the path that i've
been on
though i i first encountered larry's
work and i remember exactly
when it was i had just decided upon
a topic for my dissertation
on the mediation of holocaust's
testimony and as a film and media
scholar
i felt in over my head
i had read a great deal about the
holocaust
i had done
work going back to my undergraduate
career looking at representations of the
holocaust but i
just didn't have a sense of how to enter
into this discourse
um i needed a guide and that guide ended
up
being um larry um to
to read um
to read his work was to open up just
a whole world of possibilities for how
it was to understand testimonies
um i i had a sense in terms of
being a film and media scholar about how
the space of the screen and the sound of
the voice and the ways in which
um people perform and
uh and articulate but i
i had no sense of the kinds of
conventions
and the narrative and and rapport
and all the the aspects that went into
the process
and when reading larry's formative work
it opened up um for me
what ended up being um
the passion that drives my my my career
and i'm just forever indebted
to larry for that and i'm indebted to
the um
editors for inviting me for for giving
me the this this
ability to feel honored to be able to
contribute to this volume
um i'm i'm a little emotional just
because it takes me back to first
encountering larry's work into his
ongoing generosity and warmth
um that he's an honest i cannot cannot
stress honesty and frankness when he has
talked and we've talked about our ideas
my work for this volume disrupted
narratives
lauren slanger's explorations of deep
memory and holocaust testimonies
is a way of trying to trace
larry's influence the ways in which he's
been so foundational and foregrounding
the importance of examining holocaust
testimonies giving us the language
giving us um the a sense of the
conventions
which is probably not the best term but
at least a sense of
the textures and
the contours of testimonies and also
really allowing historians and other
scholars of the holocaust to look at
testimonies
not just simply as primary documents as
primary sources but as
of that is representations about their
experiences but as
other as sources in and of themselves um
in short i think larry more than any
other scholar has demonstrated
the interwoven nature of history and of
memory as it
makes its way in video testimonies i
whether it's and i've continued to
whether it's the students that i
supervise
and constantly return in the classes
that i teach
to to larry's conceptualization of the
choiceless choice
and what my work focuses in on is
particularly his
engagement with charlotte delbo's
notions of
deep and common memory and the ways
in which survivors
express common memory often in a
chronological or coherent
structure recalling in the present
moment how events unfolded in a
compartmentalized
past and in contrast
notions of deep memory taking witnesses
back to the events
reintroducing them to the range of
senses experienced at the time and
complicating and this is so
so foundational complicating any efforts
to keep that past
um at bay and that
larry more than any other scholar that i
know
compelling us to to engage the paradox
that
it is impossible to fully understand a
witness but that we must always
try to understand a witness that the
impossibility
and the obligation that must coexist in
this endeavor
has forever um shaped our understanding
of holocaust testimony and i think also
of
of of trauma more broadly and i think
and of genocides beyond the holocaust by
way of conclusion and as i
speaking from australia and starting to
do work on the stolen generations of
australia
and as i've done work on cambodia and
teach on rwanda and other genocides to
see
larry's conceptualizations and and also
his critiques of other ways of
conducting
testimonies that have been done by
various archives across the world to see
how
the debates that larry had mentioned
regards to the holocaust
continue to inform in critical ways
how we understand genocide and testimony
well beyond the holocaust so larry thank
you
again for informing all of this work
for steering all of this work and again
to the editors for
bringing his work um uh again front and
center where it belongs and as it always
has been
thank you no thank you for your um
powerful comments
um our next speaker
is dawn scotiewski dawn is
professor of literature at brandeis
university and
she's going to talk about the article
which
um she and i have co-written for this
special issue which is
on uh jankoski's testimonies gone
over today yeah um i'll talk a little
bit about the article but first i just
want to say
a round of thank yous w s merwin's poem
thank you comes to mind i don't know if
you know it but it's just thank you
thank you thank you thank you
the first thank you has to go to
lawrence langer larry
i am filled with emotion as i think
about
uh the many years now i mean almost a
decade but for me it seems like a very
long time that i've been working with
you and and
talking to you about holocaust testimony
testimonies
um a couple of years ago when you're
about to turn 90 i remember talking with
dan and thinking how could
how could we how could i ever repay you
for
all that i've learned from you and for
all you've given to the field
and this volume which i've so enjoyed
working on with dan
and gabby has been a labor of love as
well as an intellectual
a very gratifying intellectual
experience i first met larry when i was
giving a talk
about anne frank and eddie hillison at
the newton public library
in newton massachusetts and and he was
in the audience raising his hand every
so often
correcting the speakers about some
errors in
in their delivery things that they were
saying i was one of those speakers
and i was the one who was getting the
most corrections i think and at the end
of the talk
larry came to the front of the room and
he said to me
you know there were a few things i
didn't get to say that you missed in
your talk that you just you're just
wrong about and i was thinking oh my
goodness i was so
taken aback and i i knew there were
probably a lot of things but i didn't
know who this person was and i didn't
know
um what i was going to how i was going
to respond because the talk was over
and i said well you must know a lot
about this and he said well you know
i've written 11 books on the subject and
i said oh
maybe i should know your name he said
i'm lawrence langer and i almost fainted
and i i was standing in front of
lawrence langer and then
almost the next thing that happened was
he graciously invited me to come to his
house and talk more about holocaust
testimonies and we started watching
holocaust testimonies
in his living room um pretty much once a
week
so i've spent i don't know 100 over 100
hours watching testimonies with larry
and talking about so many different
aspects of them
and so you can imagine just from those
words how much
what that experience could be like and
then to have the opportunity now
to work on this volume in his honor and
to read the beautiful essays that you've
all written
and to see larry's face as he listens to
you it's just such a pleasure
i'm not going to talk a lot about the
article that dan and i wrote except to
say that
dan and i met a few years ago and one of
our first conversations was about
larry langer about his work and also
about his
interview with john karsky i'm just
going to show you
a picture that appears in our article
and i'm sharing my screen here
it's a picture of carski and he's
imitating
fdr and you'll see him right here and
uh dan and i were talking about this and
i remember larry telling me about this
this this happening in the interview and
he said you have to see this
this is his show a foundation interview
and then uh dan and i started comparing
the show foundation interview with
larry's fortune off interview with
karsky and then with uh claude lonsman
showa
and it was such a rich conversation and
the result of which is in this article
we conclude the article with this
comment which i think is so
it attempts to capture what larry is
about as a thinker and scholar
thirty years later langer's work helps
us to correct a tendency
to focus focus exclusively on the
traumatic
the historical or the performative
dimensions of a recorded testimony
instead we must keep all these theories
handy and at bay as we listen from
moment to moment across the archives
to the individual human being who
endured great suffering and acted
heroically and in lonzki's case
who insisted i can't go back in his
interview with lonesman
only to do so again and again for these
important archives
it was such a pleasure to work on this
article with dan it went through a few
iterations
and one of the most important parts of
that was talking to larry about the
article
um there's so much more i'd like to say
as far as what a pleasure it's been to
work on this volume and to work with
larry but i'm not going to take up all
of our time and i want to thank you all
for being here and thank you stephen for
hosting
and thank you to the journal and again
thanks to all the contributors and
finally thanks again
to larry thanks so much dawn
um well just quickly to say that it was
a pleasure to work with you two on
on that piece and um it's
it's really a an honor to uh to have
written it
in larry's honor so um the next speaker
um would have been barry langford but he
is uh not here so i will just
as his colleague and friend at royal
holloway i'll just advertise his article
and uh which is on uh film
american films and the americanization
of uh
of the holocaust uh and it is a
brilliant piece which
um shows as has already been said how uh
how larry's ideas
uh in this case about the
americanization of the holocaust were
in many ways way ahead of their time uh
how in some ways they have been
criticized by more recent scholarship
but he returns the argument full circle
and uh
goes back to larry's ideas and shows why
uh they're still important for
uh continuing to understand uh american
uh
films about the holocaust so it's a
really a wonderful piece
so our final contributor is um gabby
finder who's also uh
as you know one of the co-editors uh and
gabby's in the department of uh germanic
languages and literature
uh at the university of virginia so gabi
thank you very much then i too have many
thanks
i don't know i didn't know the poem by
merwin but i
don't please send it to me after the
webinar i loved what you said
um first of all i want to thank the
journal of holocaust research formerly
dapin
i want to thank me who was our editor
who helped shepherd this vine to
fruition i also want to thank
the administrative director of the
journal annabina
who is extremely patient with us and it
was a long process
but the product is very good i think
i want to thank my guest co editors for
inviting me to join them
they were the ones who conceived the
idea i'm not sure why they asked me but
when they did i was thrilled to join
them
and it was really a joint effort and
a labor of love and so i want to thank
dan
and dawn so much for inviting me
to be part of this i want to thank the
contributors
to the special issue every contribution
is special in its own way
and the issue covers such a wide range
from literature thanks to sarah
and philosophy thanks to jenny
and testimony thanks to noah
and dawn and dance dan's analysis
of karski's various testimonies barry's
analysis of the americanization of the
holocaust through film especially
through the film which i love
and glorious bastards but i now
understand why i like it better thanks
to
barry's article and for me also i will
speak about my own
contribution in a few minutes and i'm so
glad that this was the opportunity i've
been looking for to write about this
particular
piece uh thank you stephen
uh who i think is not i think i know
it's a new friend of mine
uh thank you stephen for uh hosting this
and being a friend i want to thank the
fortune of archives
thank you joanne for your wonderful
tribute to larry
in your introductory essay it really
brings larry's life
to life you know instead of we write
a bit in the abstract and joanne brought
larry
to life um finally i must thank
uh professor lawrence langer um
he's meant a lot to me in my career he
doesn't know that but he has meant a lot
to me in my career
but i also want to talk about i want to
mention a personal story that is very
important to me just
briefly in my career those of you who
know me or know my work know that i've
written a lot about jewish honor courts
of course that jewish communities
established after the holocaust
to investigate fellow jews accused of
having dirty hands and larry's um
uh notion or concept of choiceless
choice has meant a lot to me
as i have worked on this topic for years
now and continue to work on it
in general uh larry's empathic
and forthright approach to the holocaust
the holocaust testimony
has been an inspiration to me and i've
tried to emulate him but i have a
special personal story that i have
to share with all of you because it's
been important to me
and to my family and into my life
really and larry knows what i'm talking
about and don knows what i'm talking
about joanne knows what i'm talking
about
um so my father is with us today my
father and larry
are two months apart i believe that my
father is exactly two months older
than larry both are 91.
my father herbert finder is with us
today my dad is a holocaust survivor my
mother also and her family left germany
after uh the night of broken glass but
my dad was with my grandfather went
through several camps
as a young as a boy really
and uh for years i tried to persuade my
dad
to give testimony um audio
testimony he once gave in the 1980s he
gave
testimony on a cassette tape to nora
levine
and that actually one can find that on
the website of the united states
holocaust memorial museum
but you know i wanted my dad to do what
other survivors
have done so you know it's so important
to give audio testimony i couldn't
persuade him even though he has such an
interesting story
and because he always felt that younger
people who would interview him wouldn't
really
understand him couldn't understand what
he went through so he once said if he
could find
if i could persuade him find someone who
would understand
his story he would do it well i thought
of lawrence langer but i didn't really
know uh larry and then it was at a maybe
the same ajs conference in baltimore
uh to which noah referred earlier and
after no one was even on that panel i
believe
i'm not mistaken and joanne was on the
panel my good friend avi ompot was on
the panel
and afterwards i was scared to death
intimidated
because who am i i'm just a minor
scholar and larry
is such a major scholar he was on the
panel
but anyway i went afterwards and i said
we had met once before years ago they
didn't remember me
i said professor langer you know i
admire your work so much and my dad is a
holocaust survivor and he's probably
more or less your age and he always said
that he
wouldn't give testimony he has such an
important story to tell
but he won't do it because he feels that
younger people wouldn't understand him
and he said but you would understand
would you mind doing this and this was
about five or six years ago and larry
was retired and lives in boston the
fortune of archive of course is in new
haven
i said would you do and he said without
blinking and i said yes
and uh it was about five years ago in
the summer i drove my dad from new
jersey
to new haven and joanne was very
gracious to be there too
and um uh joanne and larry
interviewed my dad and um i just want to
say
there was a couple of uh stephen was
there in the control room that's where i
first met stephen
and i just want to say that that
testimony i think it's
it's important but to my family and to
me it's a gift
you know because it's something that i
will always
have and my children that's what's
really important to me it's
my children have it and i will never
forget
my how my children how they when they
saw that testimony for the first time
what an effect it had on them and they
saw it together with my dad
and i i just it
etched in my mind forever my daughter or
my child even wants to write
a um music to it so it's just
it's a gift to me and my family and i
just larry you've given me
in my family a great gift and i can
never thank you
enough for it
um so i write about
uh my article is called speak about it
very briefly
and my article is called a horrific
impression of jewish martyrdom regarding
extermination of polish jews album of
pictures
and i write about an album of photograph
called it was a multi-lingual folio
volume of
photographs from the holocaust in polish
it's called the guadalce it's translated
as extermination of polish jews
album of pictures it was published in
1946 by the
jewish central jewish historical
commission
in poland uh
to the best of my knowledge this is the
first album of its kind
uh published by a jewish institution
after the holocaust that is holocaust
of photographs um i'm not
everybody who knows me knows that i'm a
dinosaur when it comes to these things
but i'm going to try to share my screen
can you whoops wrong thing
let's see my son is here maybe he can
help me hello can you
what do you i'm gonna this one yes it
should just be
no wait it's behind that oh there it is
can you see that
does everybody see that so that's the
album uh that
i used and it's called as you see and
now um can you bring me back to
stop sharing right yeah okay so there i
am thank you
it's good to have a young person with me
to help me with these things
and my son is here helping me so uh this
was uh this
album is to the best of my knowledge the
first album of its kind
uh and it shows holocaust uh photographs
from the holocaust and the
um within uh one year after the end of
world war ii in the holocaust the
central jewish historical commission in
poland had collected
some 3 000 photographs from the
holocaust
and the interesting thing or the catch
is that most of the photos were taken by
germans it says how they came into the
possession of jews after the war is an
interesting story in itself uh um
many uh germans took they took their
lightweight cameras
they took photographs of uh every aspect
of the holocaust you know to mock
jews to torment them uh they show
themselves having a great grand old time
uh tormenting and killing jews um
they had those photographs developed by
polish uh developers
even some jewish developers and ghettos
they replicated them they gave them to
friends and
they were circulating throughout nazi
occupied poland and other places
and and both poles and jews came into
possession of many of those photographs
both during and after um world war ii
and
the holocaust the album uh
the majority of the photographs in the
archives photo archives of the central
uh jewish historical commission were
german produced photographs there were
also some that were taken by
jews and even by polls but the majority
of the photographs
had been taken by germans and the album
which it
contains some 250 photographs the
majority of the
photos in that album are german produced
photographs and i uh in my
article i discussed the dilemma that
uh the jewish historical commission and
the editor
of this um album faced and that was
they had they wanted to produce an
album of photographs from the whole
because they wanted to
evoke moral outrage among an
international community but they were
stuck with
a majority of photographs from the
german perspective of what
uh um scholars call the german gays
and i uh make the argument in my
um article that uh the editor
hello can you help me for a second again
so i want to just show you the uh let's
see if which one
doesn't work i want to show this
[Music]
which one is it this one now
oh hold on
oh there it is can you all see that it's
good to have a 20 year old son in
college who can help with these things
anyway this is the editor of the album
uh gershon tafit who himself was a
holocaust survivor who
survived the liquidation of his ghetto
jokiev who also survived the uh infamous
notorious unesco labor camp outside
uh lev leviev who lost his wife and
daughter and then after
uh the holocaust joined the central
jewish historical commission and became
the director of its photo archive or one
of the directors and the editor of
uh this um volume so i'm back so i
argue that even with the
inherent limitations of these photos in
mind taffet and his colleagues on the
jewish historical commission
decided to produce this valium because
they wanted their aim was to bring an
international mass
audience closer to the horrors of the
nazi persecution
and murder of jews now in my
i also i show a few of these photographs
in my
album and in my article i don't want to
i decided not to show the most horrific
and the worst
of the photographs but i do want to show
i did show one a
so-called body picture and i'm going to
ask my son hillel
um this one can you show that please
yes
[Music]
there it is can you see that yeah so
that is a
photograph of reserve police battalion
101
and all of you know all of you in the
field nowhere from christopher
browning's book ordinary men
this was the reserve police battalion
that was at the center of christopher
browning's investigation
in his classic book ordinary men and
this is a photo i have
i published this photo in my article uh
it's uh police reserve police battalion
101 after a ghetto roundup
and deportation of some 1 000 jews
in the ghetto of myanzi zitch podlaski
in the lublin district
uh in poland uh they were deported to
majdanek
on may 26 1943
and uh it's a gleeful
uh in it you see the gleeful members of
reserve police battalion 101
uh pointing to the spoils that they took
from the jewish victims that they had
just deported
to maidanic and
you know it's so hard uh to divine
what the motivation of um
of these men were and christopher
browning uh in his most recent volume of
the third edition revised edition of his
book ordinary men uh points to the
um fusion when we try to understand
motivation we should
think about the synergy between uh
situation and ideology
and i i agree with that uh for the most
part but i think what this does
also show this picture shows that
uh and the other pictures that appear in
the album
show what i uh just said call in my
um article the creation of a
permissive environment a uh de facto
open season um paul police poland's jews
in which uh
men in this battalion could torment
deport and kill jews with impunity and i
borrow
a phrase from my colleague and good
friend of
um along confino
his book is called a world without jews
it seems to me that the photographs
uh that appear in this album from 1946
uh display an attitude
among the germans who took them that
they could imagine
a world without jews that's the argument
that i made
but there's more to the album uh than
just that
at the end of the album uh the editor
gershom tafit
inserted a few photos taken by jews that
extol
jewish resistance and i argue that it's
an attempt
to subvert the so-called german gaze
in the album with uh the jewish gays and
i just want to show you one more
um could you show thank you
yes thank you
hold for tech hey gabby
yes i have 30 seconds
okay that's great thank you oh that's
not right
this one
yes okay does everyone see that and
that's a photo collage
um that was made in the lodge ghetto in
1941 by a survivor who took the name in
israel
um arya it's called it means we shall
survive
so this is how the album ends it ends on
a hopeful note but i just want to say
that
uh i i also am a um
uh a great fan of larry's work
and i am of course familiar with his um
concept of unheroic memory and i just
want to say that
even though it ends on a hopeful note
uh one uh the whole album though
is permeated by this idea
of unheroic memory so it there's this um
tension in the album between
ending on a high note and attestation
of the horror that the fellow polish
jews during the holocaust
thank you very much and i want to thank
everyone uh for their contribution to
uh the special issue
thank you so much gabby um ah good
okay uh well that's all the um the
contributors
uh i just wanted to add a little
personal
note uh which is that like many others
uh i met
um larry first for the first time when i
was a post-doc
in the mid 90s was also rather
intimidated
um because of course you know he was
lawrence langer
and it wasn't so many years since i've i
read
the holocaust testimonies book and was
kind of uh overwhelmed
and larry paid me the great honor of
taking me seriously and
and treating me like um like a peer and
he read
parts of my doctorate and we talked
about it
um and made me feel as though
um i was
an equal and had a contribution to make
and it was really wonderful it was
extremely important
uh for me um at that point in in my
career to to be treated like that
um by somebody like lawrence langer so
my own personal thanks as well to add to
uh to those of everybody
else's and on that um i would like
now to invite um larry to
respond to say a few words whatever
whatever you like
over to you
well can you hear me
we can hear you
you can hear me all right well i have
about a hundred things to say you know
italian to say about five of them
before i forget gabby it's very nice to
have a 20 year old son
to help you with things my friend it's
even nicer to have his 63 year old son
who is a grandfather
to help you with things so be prepared
you have a great future ahead of you
my son is my right arm and my left arm
unfortunately i wish you hadn't said one
thing
uh and it had to be echoed by dan
my entire adult life my wife has been
asking me
why do you intimidate people so much and
i tell her me
you know the nicest guy in the world i
never intimidate
anyone the minute this webinar is over
my wife is going to charge into my arms
until you see you see
see not only did you intimidate gabby
you intimidated dan
you know own up to it well it's still
not true
now my young friends
let me tell you
you something the mistake of saying well
this
fresh rift is a little late just a year
or what's in a year
uh be prepared be prepared when you
reach my age there's a lot in a year
now in writing my essay which i'm not
going to talk about my life alicorn
death i would remind them something that
i hadn't thought about before
when i visited dachau in 1955
raul hillberg was a graduate student
christopher browning was in junior high
school
and this blows my mind more than
anything
my late in life dear friend wendy lauer
was not even born
and so i've had to deal with this issue
of the passage of time
now there's no point in my repeating
that thanks to everyone you
again and again thank everyone i just
want to mention i'm sure i have no idea
how much time and energy dan and dawn
and gabby
must have put into preparing this
volume i would like to add one thanks
which
no one would mention because they didn't
know what to mention
the cover of this print in print
fresh rift is a painting by
the child survivor of the vilmagetto
samuel bach called the creation
of adam and i would like to thank bernie
parker of the pucker gallery in boston
for giving permission to use that
painting and i hope those of you who
will be
who will be getting a copy of the print
version
we'll look at that painting because it's
sandbox
post-holocaust version of michelangelo's
famous uh version of the creation of
adam on the ceiling of the
sistine chapel and when you look at the
atom
you have to ask the question that primo
levy asked is this a man
and not only that when you look at the
image of god
in that painting you have to ask the
question to ask
less often is this a god
so that painting really creates a kind
of introduction
to that volume now i read each of these
essays twice and
it was extraordinary the second time
through
i realized things i didn't read the
first time through
that these are such serious
investigations of such a variety of
issues
and i just offer my heartfelt thanks to
all of you
for contributing to this volume one of
the things i notice
i don't have time to talk about it is
that there's a kind of interaction
unintended of course because you hadn't
read each other's contributions um
relationship between some of these
essays just
imagine dawn and gabby
if jan koski
had been able to walk into the office
of president roosevelt carrying
gabby's volume under his arm and trying
to get president roosevelt to understand
what he's trying to
tell him when he went in and looked at
the condition of the jews in the warsaw
ghetto
incidentally gabby i want to think about
one thing
neither in your essay you're in your
presentation now have you shown us a
picture of one of these atrocity
photographs
and i'd like you to think about why uh
because we need to see them
and i hope you will in an email tell me
how can i get a copy of this none of the
libraries that i've checked and have a
copy
i don't even know if we have them here
now um
what i appreciated most about these
essays
is that instead of answering questions
they raise questions
all kinds of questions that have no
answers
and even maybe un
unanswerable um and i want to
only use show two examples that in the
essays
um jennifer in her
wonderful essay on the primo levy writes
the following
just one sentence considering if
something is so is not a questioning
that produces an answer rather
it is a dwelling with a painful reality
that cannot be resolved
and brackets judgment requiring our
continued
attention time and ongoing reflection
even though it can't go can't be
resolved i think it's
it's a gem of the sentence jennifer and
uh
thank you for it the other
um really moment that
concentrates in a sentence is
in sarah's essay and sarah thank you so
much i never heard of sarah kaufman in
my life
before you mentioned her and for some
reason my local library had a copy of
her book
which i took out and thank god it was
only 80 pages so i read it
i'm currently reading the new biography
by falco ulrich of adolf hitler each one
weighs about 10 pounds
each one is about 800 pages long and
just
imagine i mean hitler came to power
buses
83 years ago and in 2020 this year
volume 2 came out
full of information that hadn't been
used before so this subject is not dead
and will never die but let me read you
just that
other sentence from sarah cotton's book
because he was a jew my father died in
auschwitz how can it not be said and how
can it be said
how can one speak of that before which
all possibility of speech
ceases now uh
behind that line uh
there exists questions um which
will never have an answer because she
found out later what happened to her
father her father
a rabbi and orthodox jew
refused to work on the sabbath so as a
punishment
the germans buried him alive
and i asked myself these are the
questions that rise
who gave that order who dug it at home
what were the onlookers thinking while
it was happening
and what was her rabbi father thinking
as the dirt piled up around him these
are questions raised by the holocaust
for which we don't have the answers but
for which we
are obliged uh about which we're about
we are obliged to think i have a lot of
reflections on that but
you know we've gone more than an hour i
just want to say one more thing and then
i'm going to stop because there may be
questions and
we need to allow time for that
i watched the interview many years ago
an interview
at the fortune of archives uh from a
manner told his story
at the very end the interviewer made
what i consider to be a mistake of
asking him
do you have any final comments that
you'd like to offer
us uh that is usually an invitation for
a little moral homily
about the need to um
the need to be good to people and be
kind and not to bully and so forth
let's know what he did he said all my
life he says
i've been haunted by a question
and this is the northern return like to
end
what was the question he said
what happened to my mother
when i killed her was she alone
was she with other people was she afraid
what was she thinking i'll never know he
said
i'll never know but so an important
dimension
of holocaust studies and it happens in
so many of these essays
is exposing questions for which there is
no
answer and for which we are nonetheless
obliged to continue to continue
searching for one so i hope you young
people
and i say that from my position that
someone is not going on 92
will carry on with this kind of work uh
it's almost
inconceivable that we're approaching the
century
from the time when hitler came to power
and essays like these are still being
written
and i hope they will kind of continue to
be
for a long long time i mean i bless you
all for paying such attention to what
i've done you can't imagine
how good as well makes me feel and
being friends and not
people i've intimidated but being
friends have meant
so much to me and just looking at you
fills my heart with war so thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you larry um it's an enormous
honor and a pleasure for all of us i
think to to hear your words
and we're not intimidated anymore uh we
were just um
just reflecting on on the early days um
it's really wonderful to hear what you
say and i think i'm speaking
for myself what what you say about
asking questions that cannot be answered
is really goes to the heart of things
i think and particularly um for
historians
who like to to answer questions it
in this subject it's extremely important
to remember i think
what you've taught us which is that
there's no redemptive message to be
gained from studying the holocaust and
there are no final answers
in history or in any other respect and
i think that's an enormous contribution
and continues to be something that has
to be
repeated over and over again
particularly given
uh the state of public engagement with
the holocaust
and some of the immense
vandalizations that take place on a
daily basis so we're all
immensely grateful to you for your work
and i will also finally add here a
little
uh advertisement which is larry was too
modest to mention that
um another collection of his own essays
uh will be published
uh in uh the new year uh with powell
grave uh so we have more of larry's work
uh still to look forward to
it's the after death of the holocaust is
the title
the after death of the holocaust coming
coming to a book
thank you larry stephen do we have time
to take a question
of course there's actually one here
larry that you might like to respond to
um which i don't know we don't have a
name an anonymous attendee says
um the great presence of some art for
example the art of samuel back
um in your writing since 1995 please
comment and you already have obviously
on the painting
which adorns the cover of the journal
but i wonder if you'd like to say any
more about
about samuel buck's work yes
i came late in life to the work of sam
bock we have now
done 11 volumes together
he does a series of paintings and i
write a long
essay and bernie parker through his
misery
wizardry managed to get the volumes
published uh now and you know just say
two or three sentences about sam because
this is not really about sam
but along with um felix nussbaum
they for me are the two great artists of
the holocaust so
uh but uh sam tries to present
visually the way the holocaust has
fractured
our world uh in the years after the war
uh it's it's a unique contribution to
the world of art
uh he should be better known but i mean
people tell me again and again
i can't hang a painting like that in my
living room because i have to look at it
well it's like looking at the
photographs in
gabby's volume uh we can't look at it we
have to look at
it but if you're interested in pursuing
the work of sam block and it's certainly
worth pursuing just
go on to puppetgallery.com go into
artists go into samuel block
you'll be able to see a lot of his
paintings they're really worth
investigating
thank you larry um there's a comment
here from
uh wendy lauer it's nice to wendy's
here and wendy
says she wants to pay tribute to
your work and and um cites one of the
one particular sentence that you've that
you've written when human beings
cease to be emissaries or legacies of
love and become instead agents or
victims of power
on such a massive scale we may have
witnessed a shift
in civilization's priorities with whose
psychological bequest we continue to
struggle
would you like to comment or leave it as
it stands
ask me november 4th and i'll comment on
that
all right i under understand um
in that case um stephen
do we want to draw things to a close
uh i think so there was one question one
other question about how to
uh obtain a copy of the journal i don't
know if you wanted to say a few words
about how to to get a copy of the
journal
well for of course for those with
institutional
subscriptions to uh taylor and francis
journals
it can be obtained through your
institutional library i think for those
who
who don't have access to a university
uh library um perhaps if you go to the
maybe mikhail can comment but perhaps if
you go to the website of the journal of
holocaust research
you'll be able to see what access
options
um there are there but perhaps you could
also email
michal acharoni and ask her about that
as well
otherwise i think that's that's all the
questions so it just
falls to me to to say thank you to the
contributors again thank you to stephen
and to fortune off
archive thank you to mikhail and the
uh journal of holocaust research and
most of all thank you to larry
uh we're deeply uh honored to be able to
celebrate your work in this way uh wish
you a happy birthday and
and many more to come thank you